can we figure out how many people are in
the 808 mafia i need to get some
clarification because i tell man i know
some struggle rappers in the world
who have beats with your [ __ ] tag on
it
well you know my tag is like all over
youtube so people some people just take
my tag i feel like you know how like if
you go to like ohio you could buy like
cookies
uh bags like from the liquor store you
could buy the empty bags and you could
stuff like your shitty weed in it and
then sell it to people that's what you
don't know better i feel like that's
what's going on sometimes with your [ __ ]
no no that's what they do that's what
people do yeah because i'm like because
i don't even sell beach to like the
public i talk to people they're like
yeah i got a homie so and so from 808
mafia he gave me 30 beats and i'm like
wait you got a whole 808 mafia [ __ ]
album see you know how that goes this
way i go like this just you know once
they put the album out and if you're
assigned to me yet await my thing you
put this 30 beat out about you're gonna
get a little bill that comes from me
another album's gonna get tucked down so
it's just you know do you get on your uh
producer's heads about that like oh yeah
yeah pouring out the brand anyone's
around me is like
like one of my producers called me there
was like yo yo big bro i need to make
some money i'm gonna sell the b for
seven hundred dollars i'm like bro what
how about they cash up you a thousand
dollars bro your beat price is ten
thousand dollars right now like what are
you what are you doing yeah cause you
don't want you don't want uh your brand
to get watered down yeah i ain't doing
that i i used to go without you know i
used to go without just to make i i used
to need the money people were offering
me sometimes like you know what i'm
saying but i still just like i'm away
i'm cool